yeah so what's going on in 2023 Jeremy
and Jordan what's going on what's going
on what are you looking forward to
I'm looking forward to George and I have
some stuff coming out a lot of stuff
we've
gonna be able to reveal a lot more
information on Direct witness testimony
just you're gonna hear from people that
you wouldn't expect you'd be able to
hear from stuff George and I have talked
about but now you get to hear directly
from those individuals so I know in
January that the UFO subject is going to
blow up again because new information
will be coming to light
this was an exciting year the end of the
year the signing of the ndaa and and
what that means uh moving forward I mean
it's great in a sense it's sort of uh to
coin the old cliche it's sort of the uh
the end of the beginning not the
beginning of the end because we're we're
finally as a society moving toward
trying to figure out are these real and
are genuinely asking the question and of
course Kurt as you have learned the
answer is yes they are real and now
maybe you know in the years to come
Arrow NASA uh various scientific
organizations that are now openly
interested in the topic can can address
the bigger questions the really
important ones where are they from why
are they here who are they what's their
interest in us you know once we get
beyond the obvious question that that
our society has struggled with for 75
years and we can start digging into the
good stuff and and the tools are now in
place to do that uh Jeremy and I are
aware of some of these whistleblowers
who've been standing by ready to to
chime in and tell Congress and others uh
what they know and in fact we'd know
that some of them have already done so
um and when this comes out it's assuming
it comes out man it's going to be an
explosion so Kurt what what George is
talking about is what the The
Whistleblower protections laws are are
being implemented for we're talking
about reverse engineering UFOs we're
talking about our government physically
reverse engineering physical Hardware
that they suspect is from another world
so we're talking about programs that are
actively reverse engineering actively
exploiting these non-terrestrial
Technologies that's the claim and and
he's also talking about the idea that
people have already utilized some of
these internal mechanisms to establish
where the hardware is
so so this is something we have
knowledge of and we're hoping that this
gets out to the public because it is
happening this education is being given
on the inside
expand on that point where the hardware
is expand on that what do you mean I'm
not I'm not getting expand on that right
this second but this is something that's
being told you know within Congress
within the Senate intelligence committee
within whistleblowers coming forward you
know under uh IG investigations they're
looking into this this is something that
that George and I know for sure is
happening the people involved all the
mechanics of it and we we hope it
becomes public through the through the
right channels but I'm just it's
important for people to know it's
happening this is not something
theoretical yeah it's happening I'll
tell you Kurt my first foray into this
idea the Preposterous idea that we've
got craft and materials from some other
world some other intelligence was 33
years ago with Bob Bazaar and I know a
lot of your listeners will have problems
with Lazar story I don't care anymore I
don't care but at the time that I
proposed that that and and presented
that information in a new series it was
ridiculous even among a lot of UFO folks
not so ridiculous anymore because what
Jeremy and I have reported over the last
couple of years is there were Legacy UFO
programs that have not been made public
there were efforts to take these
materials exotic materials of Unknown
Origin put them in the hands of
aerospace companies the big players and
try to figure out how they work and when
Bob Lazar had that story a long time ago
uh you know people uh tisk tisk and and
denied it and and ridiculed it now not
so much because some of these
whistleblowers were talking about
or appearing before Congress now have
already given statements are there to
tell them about the Legacy programs that
they are real that there are these
exotic materials that reverse
engineering programs have been underway
the big question remaining is will the
public get to know about this and can
those materials be retrieved if you hand
them over to say a Lockheed or a
Northrop or a company like that is there
a paper trail that says the ownership
should be with the American public that
it has to be returned and we don't know
these whistleblowers that we're talking
about know where the bodies are buried
literally and where the material is I
mean down to the building
um
you know it's going to be really
interesting to see if uh if congress
makes that information public because we
know that they've heard some of that
testimony already
and they verified some of that testimony
we know great just so you know there are
a couple people in the waiting room I
just want you all to know that I see you
thank you please hang on for a couple
more moments okay so so can you tell me
Jeremy and and George Well whoever wants
to chime in what is the significance of
this whistleblowers act specifically for
people who don't know what the
legislation is what is it when does it
come into effect and why is it is it
groundbreaking do we feel like do you
think that this is just well much like
hey there's going to be a report coming
out then then the report is delayed and
then when it comes out you're just
disappointed it's going to be
disappointing should we get our hopes up
and what are we getting our hopes up for
several questions in there
just tackle them
go ahead Jeremy yeah I think we we both
have a a different perspective on it but
I think that we're in agreement that it
it is a huge invitation it's an
invitation and not only an invitation I
mean they're telling you that you need
to tell if there were illegal UFO
programs being done so this is kind of
like a duty so will people come forward
let's pretend like what Harry Reid said
that's from blockade will people come
forward saying I worked on reverse
engineering of non-terrestrial
Technologies well you have to be
motivated to do so but now they're
they're saying you know you need to come
forward so I think this is a this is a
big deal it's protections this is on the
the lines of like the church committee
or whatever they called it when they
were discovering all these things the
CIA was doing back you know on American
citizens this is that big this is big
enough that people have already come
forward now this is in the mechanisms of
government that are going to keep it
within the intelligence communities but
some people are going to come forward
publicly and we know this for sure so I
think this is a huge deal we've never
seen this kind of thing for the UFO
topic this type of acknowledgment and I
think someone like George who's been
seeing this for 35 years or however many
years now this is unprecedented so I'm
an optimist I'm super excited I think
you know we're kicking the doors down
but
I am the pacifist I'm the glass is half
empty if there is a way to bury this if
there's a way to keep a secret they'll
find it and we're already seeing some of
that kind of pushback Kurt you saw this
recent Wall Street Journal article there
was a New York Times pre-bunking piece
that came out in advance of the report
which wasn't even written at the time
that said oh yeah this is all
explainable that's exactly what I've
expected for a long time and I think
we're going to see more of it the closer
Congress and the public get to answers
the closer we get to actually seeing or
learning about the goodies The Meta
materials pieces of scrap metal of
Unknown Origin craft maybe bodies the
harder the pushback is going to be if I
were Lockheed and I had this stuff I
wouldn't give it back to us what you're
seeing is a significant pushback already
by the Department of Defense at the same
time they're speaking out of this side
of their mouth saying oh yeah we're all
about transparency behind the scenes
they're feeding this disinformation to
people like that reporter at the New
York Times who kind of try to dismiss it
I will bet you Kurt that you have had
pushback yourself for the fact that you
even dare to tackle this topic in a in a
very curious way uh you would even dare
ask the questions I'm sure your
colleagues have given you crap about it
and there's going to be a lot more of
that the closer we get to the goodie so
if they can find a way to bury it and
hide it they'll continue to do that you
look at the U.S Air Force they got more
information on the subject matter than
anyone and there's nowhere they don't
have a seat at the table they're not
showing up giving statements they're not
making press releases they haven't shown
up at any of the keyrings where are they
um they're not going to give it up very
easily so I'll believe it when I see it
I'm hopeful
in a sense but I'll believe it when I
see it yet people continuously and with
increased frequency come forward to
George and me and they provide
information and data and footage and
images and you know we I've been kicked
around people are saying oh you said you
know you're going to release more it's
been so long I'm on Cosmic time oh yeah
we're just starting so starting in
January of 2023 providing more for a
couple days a couple days from now
we're going to start you know providing
information that we've thoroughly vetted
and now where should they go where
should the audience go to find this
information out is their website is
their Twitter is there a YouTube right
now just go to our social media uh mine
and George's social media there's going
to be a location for that you know
that'll be you might be better but right
now I can write it in the chat and pin
it and also put it in the comments sure
so I'm at Jeremy Corbell and like George
on Twitter is G underscore nap
I would send people to mysterywire.com
that is still an active website it's a
repository of all the stories that I put
together for 30 plus years including
interviews you know uh yesterday marked
the one year anniversary since the death
of Harry Reid five years ago this month
he got things started by talking to the
New York Times about what a program at
that time they called atip Uh there's
still a lot of misinformation out there
a lot of things that have been made
murky I think on purpose but all those
interviews that we did with Harry Reid
with Lou Elizondo uh with other key
players in this it was all still on
mysterywire.com I would add this we did
a story if people are looking at big
events of 2022. we did a story about a
defense contractor named Radiance
Technologies they're located in
Huntsville Alabama they put out news
releases about the hiring of two people
one was a guy named Jay Stratton who had
been with the Office of Naval
intelligence and Dia the other was Dr
Travis Taylor whom we know as a UFO type
scientist on the History Channel and
Ancient Aliens and the secret of
Skinwalker Ranch in their release
Radiance Technologies bragged about
these two guys for their UFO work uh Jay
Stratton had been the head of the UAP
task force he'd been part of atip and
OSAP as well and they when they put out
a release about his hiring they bragged
about it I think that is a major step
for private contractors defense
contractors to go ahead and say yeah
we're interested in this in fact not
only are we interested in it we'd like
to get some contracts for it big step
for industry to make that and I I just
wanted to mention that's a pretty good
story that I think probably has fallen
through the cracks
yeah so so a question that's coming up
several times on today's show is what
story from 2022 ignites you the most now
which now I'm going to rephrase that for
you all which story from 2022 regarding
this topic is most relevant to something
that you can't reveal now for whatever
reason for later so that if I want to
put some pieces together I can
yeah I mean I'd say say there everything
George and I have reported on we've dug
really deep and we've really vetted
people and and now we're at a place
where we can bring stuff forward so I
think the 2019 swarms over the USS Omaha
USS Russell actually 10 Navy warships we
initially reported on that like what our
government said we obtained and released
information that was confined within
classified files originally but we were
able to get out the unclassified parts
and that story is going to open up
there's been a lot of attempts at
debunking it talking about how there's
red green and white lights well you
haven't heard nothing yet so I think
this is great I think that that story is
so important the one that we broke and
and I think the 2019 swarms it's just
one of many by the way that that we've
looked into but it's one we could
provide corroborative video evidence on
I think overall that story is a great
place to start we're going to learn a
lot more about that and I even say the
Bob Lazar story everything Bob said to
George in 1989 we are looking at it
through a different lens now and I think
there's there's more to tell on that
story so yeah I would I would say
something more that's coming is about
OSAP you'll recall Kurt the
Congressional hearing first public
hearing before Congress on the UFO UAP
Topic in 54 years and the defense
department was asked are there any
programs that existed in between blue
book and ATEC and they said nope sorry
nothing well that is absolutely not true
and a year ago we put out a book called
Skin Walkers at the Pentagon that had
details about the OSAP program it was a
predecessor to atip it's the one that
got 22 million dollars that went to
Robert Bigelow's bass organization they
created the largest UFO database in the
history of the world more than 200 000
cases public hasn't seen it Congress
hasn't seen it but I can tell you that
in the years since that book came out
there's a lot more more information
that's come our way interviews with key
players that we're going to be making
public in 2023 and I think uh I think
it'll blow it wide open I hope I agree
yeah and I think also Kurt so people
right now is kind of neat because we're
I'm just kind of celebrating the fact
that we have a few movies out and
they've done well and I'm trying to kind
of get people to all catch up and watch
them so uh on extraordinary beliefs for
free you can watch all three of my uh
initial movies so all three of these are
now free and go check them out uh this
is a good time to get caught up for what
you're going to be learning starting
January
so I know Jeremy and George that you got
to get going soon if you want you can
hang out you're more than welcome to get
some popcorn answer questions but if you
have to get going now then I'm just
going to introduce the next guests do
you have to go
okay I have to go but hi guess how you
doing I'll be listening okay
guys have a great have a great New Years
everybody and I'm real excited for for
the next year I'm extremely grateful to
for you all taking some time out on this
day Lily and Greg Jesse George and
Jeremy so so thank you all for coming
out and Jeremy and George we will have a
conversation when whenever you'd like to
come back on toll you're obviously both
welcome and we have a much longer
conversation this is rushed like mad
keep up the great work Kurt and I'll be
listening thank you man that's all right
okay thank you all right you just
watched a clip from an eight hour live
stream Behemoth Leviathan podcast from
theories of everything which is a
channel where we explore physics
mathematics and Consciousness what is
the Theory of Everything how do you
merge Quantum field Theory with General
relativities click here or in the
description for the full podcast where
there are several people make
appearances all the way from George
Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary Nolan to
Avi Loeb to John verveighkey to Donald
Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description